eudaimonia is an ancient Greek word
particularly emphasized by the
philosophers Plato and Aristotle that
deserves far wider currency than it has
because it corrects the shortfalls in
one of the most central governing but
insufficient words in our contemporary
language happiness when we nowadays try
to articulate the purpose of our lives
it's to the word happiness that we
commonly have recourse we tell ourselves
and others that the ultimate rationale
for our jobs our relationships and the
conduct of our day-to-day lives is the
pursuit of happiness
it sounds like an innocent enough idea
but excessive reliance on the term means
that we are frequently unfairly tempted
to exit or at least heavily question a
great many testing but worthwhile
situations
the ancient Greeks resolutely did not
believe that the purpose of life was to
be happy they proposed that it was to
achieve eudaimonia a word which has been
best translated as fulfillment what
distinguishes happiness from fulfillment
is pain it is eminently possible to be
fulfilled and at the same time under
pressure suffering physically or
mentally overburdened and quite
frequently in a tetchy mood this is a
psychological nuance that the word
happiness makes it hard to capture for
it's tricky to speak of being happy yet
unhappy or happy yet suffering however
such a combination is readily
accommodated within the dignified and
noble sounding letters of eudaimonia the
word encourages us to trust that many of
life's most worthwhile projects will at
points be quite at odds with contentment
and yet will be worth pursuing
nevertheless properly exploring our
professional talents managing a
household keeping a relationship going
creating a new business venture or
engaging in politics
none of these goals are likely to leave
us cheerful and grinning on a daily base
they will in fact involve us in all
manner of challenges that will deeply
exhaust and innovators provoke and wound
us and yet we will perhaps at the end of
our lives still feel that the tasks were
worth undertaking through them we'll
have accessed something grander and more
interesting than happiness will have
made a difference with the word
eudaimonia in mind we can stop imagining
that we're aiming for a pain-free
existence and then berating ourselves
unfairly for being in a bad mood we'll
know that we're trying to do something
far more important than smile all the
time we're striving to do justice to our
full human potential and to work in some
small but key way towards the
improvement of our species at the school
of life we believe in developing
emotional intelligence to that end we've
also created a whole range of products
to support that growth find out more at
the link on the screen now
you